[Music]
bruce springsteen everybody so we are in
the studio where the album western stars
and just about every bit of music since
2010 was recorded by Bruce Springsteen
and we're gonna have about five cameras
looking at Gayle Amber's two on Gayle
two on Bruce and one that they both
share you can't I have deep experience
without mistakes pain that's all just a
part of human existence so what does art
doing music music is it's it's a repair
shop so I'm basically a repairman I'm
trying to repair myself Brian being I've
worked at CBS for eight years right on
the Jersey Boys the big muckety-muck
who's never
I wasn't ilove the names apple and
cherry pie I have been waiting for five
years CBS this morning has been on the
air for eight and I've been asking
begging groveling because as you know
Bruce Springsteen doesn't do a lot of
interviews because he doesn't have to do
a lot of it he doesn't have to do an
interview to promote or sell anything so
I was so grateful and so appreciative
when we got the call Marilyn actually
called and said hey are you guys still
interested the answer was yes Marilyn
yes we're so interested named the time
in the place and today was the time in
the place thank you thank you
[Music]
you